The zany relationship between the Venom symbiote
and Eddie Brock in Venom was fun to watch,
but what everyone really wants to see is the
alien anti-hero take on Peter Parker.
Or at least, that's what Sony Pictures thinks.
And according to one of the movie's co-writers,
that very meet-up is in the cards right now.
In the lead-up to Venom's theatrical release
in October 2018, producers behind the movie
played coy about whether or not it would be
a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Rumors were abundant that the movie would
feature a cameo from Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
or even just Holland as Peter Parker.
Considering the reputation that the MCU has
for consistent, crowd-pleasing quality, the
confusion was to Venom's benefit.
Some people still think the movie is part
of the MCU, which, as we know now, it is not.
Here's the breakdown of how it all works.
When it comes to film rights, most of the
Marvel Comics characters are owned by Marvel
Studios, with the exception of the characters
related to Spider-Man.
According to Variety, Sony holds the rights
to about 900 characters from the Spider-Man
corner of the Marvel Comics universe.
So if Sony owns Spider-Man, then why has Peter
Parker been hanging out with the Avengers
so much?
"Kid, you're an Avenger now."
After the disappointing critical and commercial
performance of Sony's Amazing Spider-Man 2,
Sony and Marvel worked out something of a
shared custody agreement for Spider-Man, giving
Marvel creative rights to the character for
a stretch of five movies.
Those movies include Captain America: Civil
War, Spider-Man: Homecoming, Avengers: Infinity
War, Avengers: Endgame, and Spider-Man: Far
From Home.
As part of the agreement, Sony apparently
gave up the right to produce their own live-action
Spider-Man movies.
But when Far From Home comes out, that deal
will be done for, and Sony could then potentially
take Spider-Man back for themselves.
Now that Venom has proven to be a massive
financial success, earning more than $850
million worldwide since its release, it's
increasingly looking like Sony will be taking
Spider-Man off Marvel's hands.
In the "Designing Venom" special feature included
in the home release of the Venom movie, co-writer
Jeff Pinkner teased the likely
possibility of a Venom-Spider-Man crossover,
going so far as to assert that Spider-Man
already exists in Venom's universe.
The topic was brought up as a part of a discussion
about fan outrage over the movie's redesign
of Venom, with the white spider emblem across
the character's chest being removed for the
live-action adaptation.
In the comics, Venom gets the spider emblem
thanks to the symbiote first bonding with
Peter Parker.
But in this version of Venom's origin, the
symbiote goes straight to Eddie Brock, with
no Spider-Man connection.
As a result, Venom's chest in the movie is
bare black.
"In a movie where Spider-Man exists in the
universe, but does not exist in our story,
it would make no sense."
But as Pinkner puts it, that aspect of the
movie Venom's design could change if he and
Spider-Man ever manage to encounter each other.
"In a future movie down the line, that a symbiote
and Spider-Man might not share a moment, and
that symbiote might end up with the Spider-Man
emblem splashed across its chest."
Speaking to Screen Rant before Venom's release,
director Ruben Fleischer characterized a Spider-Man
and Venom crossover as being a sure thing,
eventually.
He also said that the Spider-Man they would
want to use for the crossover wouldn't be
a new actor, but instead the current Peter
Parker performer, Tom Holland.
The filmmaker said,
"I think we laid the groundwork in this film
for a pretty fun match-up in the future…
It feels like that's inevitable, and I know
that Tom Holland's excited about it, and I
know that Tom Hardy's excited about it, so
it's just a question of when and where, I
guess.
That seems like the natural evolution."
Sony has been laying track for a Spider-Man
crossover since before Venom was released,
reportedly toning the movie down for a PG-13
rating in order to make it easier for the
two characters' stories to match up with each
other.
It remains to be seen how the filmmakers would
go about making a crossover happen now that
Venom's origin story is so different.
In the comics, the symbiote was rejected by
Peter before latching on to Eddie, who held
his own grudges against Spider-Man.
Their mutual hatred of Spider-Man made them
a natural nemesis, and it's unclear how a
crossover would reverse engineer that relationship.
There's also the fact that Tom Hardy's Eddie
is a grown man who lives in San Francisco,
and Tom Holland's Peter is a high school student
who lives in New York City.
Also, the Venom in Venom is kind of a good
guy, why would he want to go beat up a high
school kid?
These issues make it harder to imagine how
a team-up movie would actually work, but if
the suits at Sony want it bad enough, it's
probably going to happen, especially since
their take on Venom made so much money.
Who cares about the story, right?
There's money to be made.